This is BammBamm.
He's a babirusa.
Yes, that is a real animal.
A member of the pig family, this prehistoric-looking creature...
...is native to the small Indonesian island of Sulawesi.
In males, the upper canine teeth grow straight up...
...through the flesh of its own snout and curve back towards their eyes.
As they get older, the tusks can get spectacularly large,...
...and on rare occasions, have grown so big as to pierce their own skulls.
Babirusas spend much of their time foraging for food,...
...eating everything from roots, leaves and fruits, to meat and grubs.
His strong jaws are easily capable of cracking the hardest of nuts.
In its native island home, the babirusa has no natural predators,...
...but overhunting and conversion of their rainforest habitat to farmland...
...has reduced their wild population to less than a few thousand.
This is the babirusa.